[Music]
hello everyone
i'm utsunomiya from the pokemon company
today i'm happy to share with you our
latest updates on a number of games
first we'd like to share some news about
pokemon's first strategic team battle
game pokemon unite
the nintendo switch version of the game
has already been released and the
release of a mobile version has now been
set for september 22nd
in anticipation of the mobile version
launch pre-registration has begun today
on the app store and google play store
nintendo's switch and mobile device
users can play together in pokemon unite
we hope as many people as possible will
be able to enjoy playing it together
players will also receive special gifts
in their game based on the number of
people who pre-registered for the mobile
version thanks to a special campaign
happening now
we hope you'll all pre-register and look
forward to the mobile release
players who are quick to jump in with
the nintendo switch version that has
already been released can also receive
zera aura's unite license as a launch
bonus
the unite license can also be used in
the mobile version by linking accounts
and finally i'd like to give you all a
preview of some of the pokemon that are
slated to join in future updates
[Music]
look forward to more from pokemon unite
in the future
now i'd like to share some news about a
few of our other games
pokemon cafe mix is getting a revamp and
with it a new title
pokemon cafe remix
the puzzles have been refreshed with the
addition of new elements with which you
can mix link and blast puzzle icons
[Music]
there will be tons of pokemon new to
pokemon cafe remix and new dress-up
options
you'll also find more ways of growing
and developing your staff pokemon so
this renewed puzzle game is sure to be
something that can be enjoyed for years
to come
pokemon cafe remix will open its doors
this fall
[Music]
pokemon masters ex celebrates its
two-year anniversary
[Music]
dynamaxxing is here signature leon has
arrived and he's partnered up with
eternitis
team up with brothers leon and hob to
face eternitis in the legendary event
currently underway
[Music]
to celebrate the two-year anniversary of
pokemon masters ex players will get the
chance to scout up to 100 sink pairs at
no cost plus three different legendary
events are returning at once meaning
players can team up with three legendary
pokemon
and will be returning in a special
outfit as part of a master's sink pair
and in his pokemon are able to target
all opponents with their attacks look
forward to seeing n as well as other
two-year anniversary sync pairs soon
then starting in september a new story
arc unfolds villainous organizations are
stirring once more as the story takes a
darker turn you won't want to miss it
we have plenty of other events and
exciting content planned as well so come
join us in celebration of this special
anniversary
also if you log into the game after this
presentation you can receive a present
of 3 000 gems as our newest campaign
begins you won't want to miss it
[Music]
pokemon go which is celebrating its
fifth anniversary will have pokemon that
were first discovered in the gala region
appearing in the wild the ultra unlock
part 3 sword and shield event will begin
on august 20th 2021 at 10 am local time
players can look forward to seeing wulu
squavit and phalanx during the event the
legendary pokemon zashian and zamazenta
will also be appearing in five star
raids
it seems that the sudden appearance of
pokemon originally discovered in the
gala region has something to do with the
mischievous tricks of a certain mythical
pokemon be sure to take part in these
events and discover the truth behind
these curious appearances
your adventures in the real world will
only continue to grow and pokemon go
[Music]
next up we have some news about the
pokemon brilliant diamond and pokemon
shining pearl games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the release of pokemon brilliant diamond
and pokemon shining pearl is now just
three months away
let's review the main points of these
revitalized games
after 15 years pokemon diamond and
pokemon pearl have been reborn
into pokemon brilliant diamond and
pokemon shining pearl
[Music]
this adventure takes place in the sinnoh
region of land rich in nature with
towering mount coronet at its heart
as the protagonist you'll adventure
across the region catching wild pokemon
and making new friends as you strive to
complete your pokedex
along with your partner pokemon you'll
overcome the gym leaders of each area
and aim to become the champion
you'll also encounter traces of the
sinnoh region's myths passed down
through the generations and unravel the
truth behind their mysteries
[Music]
this is professor rowan who entrusts you
with a pokemon he's a famous professor
researching pokemon evolution
this is your childhood friend and rival
he hones his skills as a pokemon trainer
through your friendly rivalry
[Music]
rorke is one of the gym leaders you'll
take on during your journey he uses rock
type pokemon
everywhere you look team galactic is up
to something there appears to be some
sort of lofty goal behind all their
audacious activity
cynthia is investigating myths about
pokemon she's a mysterious person who
shows up at many points along your
journey
gameplay features from pokemon diamond
and pokemon pearl have been revamped and
powered up for these new games
in the grand underground you can
participate in a number of activities
such as digging up fossils or creating
your own secret base and decorating it
with pokemon statues
there are also places down there called
pokemon hideaways which didn't exist in
pokemon diamond and pokemon pearl
apparently the pokemon that appear in
the pokemon hideaways will change
depending on which statues you have
placed in your secret base it seems that
some of the pokemon living in the sinnoh
region can only be found in this place
so be sure to fully explore the grand
underground spread out beneath the
surface of sinnoh
you can use the stickers you'll collect
on your adventure to customize the
effects that appear when pokemon spring
out of pokeballs such as confetti or
fireworks by collecting stickers at
various locations along your journey and
decorating with them you can make your
pokemon battles even more fun
one new feature that was not available
in pokemon diamond and pokemon pearl is
the ability to change your outfit
wear your favorite styles on your
adventure
in super contest shows your pokemon can
dance to the rhythm of the music proudly
show off a contest move and aim for a
successful show
cooperate with your partner pokemon to
really work up the crowd
[Music]
in the union room this release allows
you to use not only local communication
but also online communication to
interact with trainers all over the
world in real time
please enjoy battles and pokemon trades
with many other trainers
you can walk around with any of the
pokemon that appear in these games enjoy
your journey through sinnoh together
with your partner pokemon
encounters with all kinds of people and
pokemon and the mystery behind sinnoh's
myths await you
we hope you look forward to starting an
exciting adventure with new gameplay
features in the cinno region
[Music]
please wait just a bit longer for the
start of your adventure
but that's not all
a special nintendo switch light yaga and
palki edition will also be released to
celebrate the launch of these games
this special nintendo switch light is
dressed up with art of the legendary
pokemon dialga and palkia bringing to
mind the special nintendo ds light onyx
the alga and palkia edition that was
released back in 2006 to align with the
original game's launch
it will be available to purchase
beginning november 5th 2021. look
forward to it
next we have some information for you
about the pokemon legends arceus game
which is being developed by game freak
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
that was the latest trailer for pokemon
legends arceus
let's take a closer look at some of the
elements introduced in the video
pokemon legends arceus is a brand new
title that opens new doors for the
pokemon series by fusing action with rpg
elements
your adventure takes place in a region
known as sisui during a long ago era
when it was rare for people to live in
harmony alongside pokemon mount coronet
towers over the center of the land with
sprawling diverse natural environments
surrounding the mountain on all sides
these different areas are home to a rich
variety of pokemon ecosystems
in the future this land of hisoui will
come to be known as the sinnoh region
you'll set out on an adventure with the
goal of completing the first ever
pokedex for the hisoui region
[Music]
the bustling jubilee village will be the
base for your adventures
it's home to the galaxy expedition team
made up of people from various other
regions
with divisions such as the medical corps
the security corps and the survey corps
which researches pokemon
professor lavinton's field of study is
the ecology of pokemon he came to the
hisui region along with pokemon he met
in various other regions he entrusts one
of these pokemon to you
captain cylene is the leader of the
survey corps though she may seem to
treat you harshly deep down she's your
biggest supporter and she watches over
your progress with care
commander commodo oversees the entire
galaxy team he's a dependable leader who
has earned the unwavering trust of his
team members
when the commander recognizes your knack
for pokemon research he allows you to
join the team and has you work as a
member of the survey corps
the duty of the survey corps is to
observe and catch pokemon to shed light
on how they live
your survey duties hold the key to
unlocking the true purpose of your
adventure and in the course of your work
you'll visit various locations within
the hisui region
your excursions outside the village will
begin by preparing at a base camp at
these camps you'll be able to prepare
for your survey work by buying items or
crafting new ones from basic materials
in the hisui region you'll find that
you'll be vulnerable to attacks from
wild pokemon take too much damage from
their attacks and you'll black out so
use caution when you're out doing your
survey work
when your pokemon are hurt you can
return to a base camp to rest up and
recover
once you've completed a survey
assignment return to the village and
report the results to whoever requested
the job
[Music]
pokemon live all over the place
get close to them and aim carefully then
throw a pokeball to try to catch them
you'll find that not all species of
pokemon react the same way when they
spot you for example some pokemon will
immediately flee so you'll want to hide
in tall grass when you approach them
aggressive pokemon on the other hand may
need to be weakened in battle there are
a variety of tricks to catching them all
[Music]
throw a pokeball containing one of your
own pokemon near a wild pokemon and a
battle will begin
you'll find that a single pokemon may
get to act multiple times in a row
depending on its speed stat and the
moves that it uses you can also choose
to have pokemon use their moves in two
different styles strong style and agile
style using a move in the strong style
will increase the move's power but the
pokemon's action speed will be lowered
using a move in the agile style will
decrease the move's power but the
pokemon's action speed will be raised
you'll find the strong style will come
in handy when you see a chance to end a
battle with one powerful move while the
agile style is great for situations
where acting multiple times in a row
will give your battle strategy a real
boost use these different styles as the
situation demands to gain the upper hand
in battle
when you report the results of your
survey work to the professor information
will be added to the pokedex
you can advance your research and fill
in more information by doing things like
catching pokemon seeing them use certain
moves multiple times and more seek out
and meet lots of different pokemon to
complete that pokedex
[Music]
now we'd like to introduce some of the
pokemon living in the rich natural
environments that are spread out across
the hisui region
this pokemon with distinctive antlers is
known as weirdier weirder evolves from a
stantler that has managed to live in the
harsh natural environment of the hisoui
region
it has strong ties with the local people
and it has been treated with great care
and respect in this land since ancient
times
garments made with the first shed from
its beard tail and legs are highly
prized as warm winter clothing
this pokemon is basky legion it can swim
with great power masculine that live in
the hisui region can evolve into this
pokemon if they become possessed by the
restless souls of other masculine in
their school that have perished during
their journey upstream this pokemon
gains power from the souls possessing it
letting it swim on and on without tiring
there are also pokemon that can be found
living in this land and forms that have
adapted to the environment of the hisui
region
this pokemon with its great majestic
wings is the hisouyan form of braviary
it comes to husuhi in the winter and can
imbue its screeches with psychic power
to generate shock waves
this pokemon which works with a partner
is the hisoian form of growlithe it is a
very weary pokemon and appears to
protect its territory kisui and growless
soft fur is an excellent insulator
allowing it to stay active and lively
even in this chilly land the horn on its
head is made of rock but it breaks
easily so heisuy and growlithe uses it
only when it'll have the greatest effect
the pokemon arceus holds the key to this
story but what connection does it have
to your adventure
[Music]
we hope you look forward to finding out
on the day when you can finally meet the
people and pokemon of the hisui region
for yourself
[Music]
those were our latest updates on these
new entries in the pokemon series
[Music]
pre-orders for pokemon legends arceus
pokemon brilliant diamond and pokemon
shining pearl will become available on
nintendo eshop after this broadcast
we'd also like to announce that support
for these titles is planned to come to
pokemon
the cloud service for nintendo switch
and compatible mobile devices in 2022
keep an eye on our upcoming
announcements for further details
[Music]
as for the ranked battles that so many
of you continue to enjoy
these will take place as before in
pokemon sword and pokemon shield
we hope you all have fun participating
in even more competitive play in the
future
[Music]
those are all the latest updates we can
share with you today
we hope you're looking forward to all
the exciting pokemon adventures to come
thank you all for tuning in and watching
[Music]
you